here's a fun fact for you Alicia Keys is
a goddess no question another fun fact
Alicia Keys is an active member of the
kundalini yoga community here at Rama in
Venice California Kate Hudson's a fan
too by the way and if it's good enough
for those amazing ladies you could
definitely say I'm interested so we're
gonna check it out today I'm actually
doing Kundalini Yoga next week I've
never done it before
yes yes any words of wisdom or just like
going wide open
[Music]
so we've been doing that mantra every
day since the Chinese New Year last year
so almost up on a year it just makes you
rich and beautiful and stuff I think
it's working
so first of all tell me about the
differences between Kundalini Yoga and
the Yoga vinyasa that people are used to
well Kundalini Yoga is a science and not
that vinyasa isn't in a certain way but
it's very much kind of a pure science
we're working on prescriptive things and
you can do them in very short amounts of
time so you don't have to commit to like
an hour and hour and a half I think that
Yogi Bhajan knew that we're going to be
in the technological age the teacher who
brought Canole yoga to the West and that
people don't have the time and they need
results and they need results fast so
Kundalini Yoga is very fast and get a
nice little workout you can get a nice
little kind of mind clearing in 10
minutes
[Music]
tell me about how you and Alicia came to
be well Alicia was referred to me by one
of our mutual friends and she just is
such an incredible bright human being
doing such a powerful work on this
planet and I feel very blessed to know
her and be by her side can you speak a
little bit to how Kundalini Yoga has
impacted Alicia's life well I you know I
think that she could speak better to
that but I was saying this to her two
nights ago she looks so much more
radiant every time I see her so I'm a
proof in the pudding kind of person like
you can say these things do certain
things but then when I see it that
clearly and she was radiant already so
like when you know this is really like
booming as human beings were wired for
happiness
that's what Kundalini means Kundalini is
about your inherent birthright of
happiness it's not you know it sounds
kind of fancy but it's just about you
being you and we don't know who you are
you don't know who you are we don't know
who you are so let's just like see what
happens if we kind of make a road
towards ourselves instead of running
away from ourselves at every chance we
get you mentioned during class the Rouge
thing that you don't need to use your
good Yogi Bhajan said this exercise put
such circulation and beauty into your
cheeks that you will never need
cosmetics that's for all my men out
there you don't need to wear Rouge
anymore Yogi Bhajan gave all of these I
call them yogic beauty secrets there's
so many breaths and and postures to keep
the skin glowing and to keep the the
body in a vital kind of place and also
the mind a pituitary gland the pineal
gland the hypothalamus these kind of
glandular centers in the brain those are
solely responsible for the way you age
so every time you do a Kundalini Yoga
Kriya meditation it stimulates those
parts of the brain centers I personally
have found that like I just get more
radiant my skin gets more glowing and
everything just gets healthier and more
vital and that's
exciting so it's proof in the pudding
our belief is we want you to be more you
whatever way that is
and so you we're not anti anything like
whatever makes you feel good but what we
find is that when you turn inside and
you start to kind of experience yourself
maybe you don't feel so compulsively in
need of covering yourself up in any way
steady rhythm this cleans your blood so
that when you get into that kind of
recycle the oxygen environments
keep yourself from kind of jet lag
experience tell me about the book
invincible living yeah what can people
expect from reading your book 80 million
people want to try yoga in 2017 but
there are reasons why they think that
they can't do it and most of them are
you know I don't belong in a yoga class
or I can't touch my toes or what if I
don't know what they're yeah I mean so
this book invincible living is a is
really a no barrier to entry you can be
sitting at your desk you can be waiting
for your kids to get out of school you
do a little we'll start with this little
9 minute set that if you do it every day
during the holidays it's guaranteed that
you can digest more carbohydrates just
letting you know ok so now you're gonna
bring the legs up 6 inches off the
ground and you're gonna stretch the
fingers to the toes you're going to look
at the toes and you're gonna begin
breath of fire which is an equal inhale
exhale through the nose what about the
people in Oklahoma North Dakota how can
they practice well one way they can
practice is with me on Rama TV which is
my online platform and my my class goes
wherever we are in the world it goes up
every single day and there's all all of
my trainings and my women's intensives
so we have people from 180 countries
doing my class every day doing our
trainings with us and participating in
all sorts of virtual ways and I really
created it because I you know want to
have everyone have an experience and
have access so and obviously invincible
living you know you can pick that up get
some get some goods from there as well
so that was my first time doing
Kundalini Yoga and really my first time
doing yoga I kind of came into the
experience blind gurus I get promises me
that I will be sore tomorrow in the arms
and the legs and I already feel it a
little bit now she's also instructed me
to keep doing the cat cow 30 minutes a
day and that will help my collagen in my
face so I can't wait to see how that
pans out and I'm going to keep doing it
thanks so much for coming with me on
this journey I am feeling more sad
already and I hope you are too for more
exclusive content things you will not
find anywhere else
be sure to click Subscribe
[Music]
you
[Music]